they've lost daughters and sons a year
after the collapse of Rana Plaza they're
still mourning the dead and demanding
compensation from the international
companies whose contractors made clothes
there a memorial for the most
devastating accident in the history of
the garment industry and of a system of
exploitation when you come here you
immediately feel a deep sadness you see
things on the ground like clothes and
bits of fabric and things that remind
you of everyday life in the factory he's
really upset
Martinez Schmidt works with the GI Z in
Bangladesh he runs a project aimed at
improving conditions in the factories
those can turn everyone even the clothes
I'm wearing right now come from
Bangladesh people give their lives here
to make clothes for Europeans it's
pretty shocking this show kid I'm not
sure these in Bangladesh there are more
than 5,000 clothing factories employing
four million people in this industry the
pressure is immense
after Rana Plaza few factories are
prepared to open their doors to
journalists but we are allowed to film
here a model factory where Jonna to
effect do she works before this I never
worked anywhere for long I couldn't take
the other factories for more than five
or six months but here it's okay
I've been here seven years the firm's
that order clothes from here are mostly
European they include CNA it has sourced
clothes from this factory for years
working with GI Z and Magnus Schmidt
sadly safety standards are still bad in
many factories for example the firewalls
are inadequate the stairways don't have
fireproof doors and teams aren't trained
to respond if a fire breaks out that's
what's missing from a lot of factories
Schmidt and the C&A Foundation are
trying to improve product and safety
standards in the factories the
foundation's pilot project is running in
five of the firm's 150 factories in
Bangladesh so is the project just a PR
exercise if it was just for the image we
wouldn't be continuing to be testing it
you know and we're also sharing the
lessons actually to the entire industry
so right now via in the middle of
publishing a case study about the
program because I think we can learn a
lot before we scale up the program but
other brands can learn as well the idea
of suddenly introducing European
production standards isn't popular with
many factory owners in Bangladesh but
owner Fuad abdullah sees it as an
opportunity still the biggest problem he
faces is buyer's pressure to keep prices
low international companies come to
Bangladesh because they know that wages
are low here if you ask me that way I
don't think there's a fairness but
that's how the world is budget for
clothing is the least for people there
will be money for a mobile phone there
will be money for holidays but everyone
look for $10 jeans and it's driven by
the market demand it's not the buyers I
don't trying to sell it cheap in
Bangladesh the minimum wage for garment
workers has just risen to 50 euros a
month
with lots of overtime seamstress John
Atul fig do she can make 85 euros per
month but in Dhaka rents rise with
garment workers wages and like many
'[ __ ] do she also has a family to
support of course I miss my family I
live here by myself my father my mother
they all live far away in the country
even when things aren't going so well
I'm still the only one who's earning so
I sent home as much as I can 1,100
people died at Rana Plaza 2,000 more
were injured some severely many victims
of the accident are still struggling to
recover
Reihana Akhtar was forced to go to work
on the day of the accident though there
was already a gaping hole in the
building a wall and then the ceiling
collapsed on her she lost her leg Rehana
has received some money from the
government but none from the clothing
companies is my leg really only worth
9,000 euros for the rest of my life I've
lost the chance to earn good money and I
can't help out my family anymore
I could go back to work at some point if
I had a better prosthesis the companies
whose clothes were produced at Rana
Plaza have agreed to compensate the
victims but so far less than half of the
plan 29 million euros have been paid
into the fund
critics say the firms are playing for
time the fact that it takes such a huge
accident with more than 1100 people dead
to actually get the ball rolling makes
me pretty mad sometimes some factories
have been shut down due to poor safety
standards a small victory in the fight
to stop another disaster